اذا كان عليك ترك منزلك للهروب الى بلاد
اخرى فما هو الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكن ان
تاخذه معك وكاله الامم المتحده للاجئين
سالت السوريين هذا السؤال ووثقت اجوبته في
مقطع فيديو مصور اكثر من مليون لاجئ عبر
الحدود ولقد شاركو قصصهم التي مروا بها
خلال الحرب البشعه عبد الله حمل معه
مفاتيح شقته بدمشق وقد غادر هو وزوجته
واطفاله العاصمه السوريه بعد ان اصيبت
زوجته خلال المعارك ويسكن عبد الله الان
مع عائلته في ماوى الخشبي بوادي البقاع في
لبنان وهو لا يعلم ما بقي من بيته الان
لكنه يحلم يوميا بالعوده اليه ويقول عبد
الله ساراكم باذن الله في مثل هذا الوقت
من العام المقبل في
دمشق اما يوسف فقد اخذ معه هاتفه الخليوي
عندما هرب من دمشق وهو يسكن الان في مبان
وادي البقاع اللبناني ويقول يوسف ان هذا
الجهاز الصغير هو طريقه التواصل الوحيده
مع اهله سواء عبر سماع اصواتهم او مشاهده
صورهم المخزنه عليه من خلال هذا الجهاز
استطيع ان اتصل بوالدي فنحن قريبون جدا من
سوريا بحيث انني استطيع ان التقط اشاره من
ابراج الاتصالات هناك وبالنسبه لليلى فهي
تبلغ التاسعه من العمر فقط وقد غادرت مع
اهلها بعد مقتل جيرانها وهم يقيمون مؤقتا
في بيت غير مكتمل البناء كردستان العراق
وقد اخذت ليلى معها بنطال جنز مميز كانت
تلبسه للاعراس تقول ليلى عندما رايت
البنطال علمت بانه الاختيار المثالي لانه
يحتوي على رسمه ورده وانا احب الورود
تمارا وعائلتها غادروا سوريا بعد ان دمر
منزلهم في ادلب عندما غادرنا منزلنا شعرنا
وكان السماء تمطر رصاصا كان هذا تعليقها
وهم في طريقهم الى الحدود التركيه وتظهر
هذه الصوره كيف انها تحمل شهاده الدبلوم
الخاصه بها بكل فخر في مخيم اللاجئين الذي
تعيش فيه وليس من الضروري ان يكون الشيء
المهم الذي تاخذه معك ماديا او ملموسا
ايمن يبلغ من العمر 82 سنه ويقول ان زوجته
ياسمين هي اغلى ما عنده انها افضل امراه
عرفتها في حياتي ولو امكنني العوده 55
عاما الى الوراء لاخترتك مره اخرى وهجر
ايمن وزوجته منزلهما في حلب بعد مقتل
جيرانهما ونهب وحرق البيوت
المجاوره هذه هي الوجوه الحقيقيه
لسوريا هكذا فان هؤلاء اللاجئين ستتغير
حياتهم للابد بعد الهروب من الحرب
وانفصالهم عن كل ما عرفوه وعز عليهم اخذين
معهم فخرهم وتراثهم وجزءا من
ديارهم